a cult classic beloved by its legions of
devoted fans Veronica Mars put a fresh
spin on the TV mystery genre former
young adult novel author Rob Thomas
created the show a modern-day
combination of noir and Nancy Drew and
it ran for three seasons on UPN and a CW
years later the show would be
resurrected as a successfully crowd
funded movie let's explore the real
reasons why Veronica Mars was cancelled
low ratings television networks or
businesses and low rated shows tend to
be poor investments yeah this serves as
a pre-emptive apology of this
conversation that's about to take place
in its first season back in fall of 2004
Veronica Mars ranked a dismal 148 out of
156 total shows it takes up a bit to 145
in its second season and 138 in his
third and final year all the while total
viewership held steady at about 2.5
million viewers Tara said CW
Entertainment president Don ostrov at a
TV industry event shortly after the
cancellation we really tried every
single year to bring in more viewers and
we just weren't able to crack it maybe
that's true but the network didn't do
Veronica Mars any favors by scheduling
it against Fox's American Idol at the
peak of its popularity that is slightly
disturbing tough fit with the CW in 2006
the two struggling networks the WB and
UPN merged into a new network called The
CW which became Veronica Mars's new home
this face right here
my over the moon face sadly despite
surviving the merger it wasn't an easy
fit even though CW corporate sibling
Warner Brothers Studios produced
Veronica Mars it was cancelled because
it couldn't draw in new viewers so are
you gonna tell me why I'm here or should
I just sit back and enjoy your
impression of a mildly constipated David
Caruso that's because the CW is going
after a couple of very specific audience
niches and Veronica Mars a difficult to
categorize show that was a little funny
and a little dramatic didn't fit in with
the vampires and superheroes ahead of
its time Veronica Mars ran on broadcast
TV just before the so-called second
Golden Age of television and before
streaming services open up new
opportunities for quirkier shows of the
kind Rob Thomas Creed's before shows
like breaking bad and Game of Thrones
found accolades for their intricate
plotting that required viewers to pay
close attention and watch every episode
TV shows that dare to be innovative
maduk and complicated or often
critically acclaimed but commercially
ignored Veronica Mars aired her on the
same time as Arrested Development
another show that pulled in a small but
devoted audience of fans who appreciated
precision kakuka
tap CooCoo cacha yeah doing my god women
I was just gonna touch no reboot while
Veronica Mars was still in the air some
CW executives asked Thomas to write a
show about rookie cops he countered with
the idea of making the fourth season of
Veronica Mars jump forward in time to
show Veronica and her first year as an
FBI agent and they produced a pilot
presentation a mini episode about 12
minutes long while well-received by the
CW brass the reboot wasn't meant to be
Thomas explained an interview that he
thinks CBS president les Moonves killed
it
we went from dead to back on the air to
dead again very quickly our Hail Mary
pass came very close to working but
didn't quite get past all the filters
needed to moving on probably seeing the
writing on the wall Thomas had already
secured his next gig by the time the
series was wrapping up its third season
those days were over and it's time to
move on he was hired on as a writer and
producer for ABC's misguided a sitcom
starring Judy Greer as a high school
guidance counselor Thomas was quickly
promoted to showrunner and executive
producer but left the series after only
a few weeks due to creative differences
misguided was ultimately a midseason
replacement that aired only 7 episodes
in the spring of 2008 freeing up Grier
to move on to better things
resurrection Veronica Mars as hardcore
fans couldn't let go and neither could
the show talent for years after the
cancellation Rob Thomas and star Kristen
Bell mentioned the possibility of a
movie in interviews it seemed like a
long shot for a studio to finance a
big-screen version of a show very few
people watched what are we gonna do this
whole Veronica Mars movie out I gotta
have a million dollars lying around but
then Along Came Kickstarter in March
2013
Thomas launched a campaign to finance
the movie directly from fans within 30
days the project had collected an
astonishing 5.7 million dollars wait for
it
yeah I love all 91,000 of you from the
whole cast thank you so very very much
Thomas took a screenplay and his
Kickstarter money to Warner Brothers and
the studio kicked in a few more million
to get the movie made it was released to
theaters and a video on demand platforms
of March 2014 thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos at the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you love the most about
Veronica Mars